the mayor of a town saw an article that
claimed the national unemployment rate
is eight percent they wondered if this
held true in their own town so they took
a sample of 200 residents to test the
null hypothesis is that the unemployment
rate is the same as the national one
versus the alternative hypothesis which
is that the unemployment rate is not the
same as the national where p is the
proportion of residents in the town that
are unemployed the sample included 22
residents who were unemployed assuming
that the conditions for inference have
been met and so that's the random normal
and independence conditions that we've
talked about in previous videos identify
the correct test statistic for this
significance test
so let me just i like to rewrite
everything just to make sure i've
understood what's going on we have a
null hypothesis that the true proportion
of unemployed people in our town that's
what this p represents is the same as
the national unemployment and remember
our null hypothesis tends to be the no
news here nothing nothing to report so
to speak and we have our alternative
hypothesis that no the true unemployment
in this town is different
is different than eight percent
and so what we would do is we would set
some type of a significance level we
would assume that the mayor of the town
sets it let's say he sets or she sets a
significance level of
0.5
and then what we want to do is conduct
the experiment so this is the entire
population of the town
they take a sample of 200 people so this
is our sample n is equal to 200. since
it met the independence condition we'll
assume that this is less than 10 percent
of the population
and we calculate a
sample statistic here and it would be
since we care about the true population
proportion the sample statistic we would
care about is the sample proportion and
we figure out that it is 22 out of the
200 people in the sample are unemployed
so this is 0.11
now the next step is assuming the null
hypothesis is true
what is the probability of getting a
result this far away or further from the
assumed population proportion and if if
that probability is lower than alpha
then we would reject the null hypothesis
which would which would suggest the
alternative but how do you figure out
this probability
well one way to think about it is we
could say how many standard deviations
away from the true proportion the
assumed proportion is it and then we
could say what's the probability of
getting that many standard deviations or
further from the true proportion we
could use a z table to do that and so
what we want to do is figure out the
number of standard deviations and so
that would be a z statistic
and so how do we figure it out well we
can figure out the difference between
the
sample proportion here and the assumed
population proportion so that would be
0.11
minus 0.08
divided by the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution of the sample
proportions and we can figure that out
remember all that is is and sometimes
well we don't know what the population
proportion is but here we're assuming a
population proportion so we're assuming
it is 0.08
and then we'll multiply that times 1
minus 0.08 so we'll multiply that times
0.9
and this comes straight from we've seen
it in previous videos the standard
deviation of the sampling distribution
of sample proportions and then you
divide that by n which is 200 right over
here and we could get a calculator out
to figure this out but this will give us
some value which says how many standard
deviations away from 0.08 is 0.11 and
then we could use a z table to figure
out what's the probability of getting
that far or further from the true
proportion and then that will give us
our p-value which we can compare to
significance level
sometimes you will see a formula that
looks something like this that you say
hey look you have your sample proportion
you find the difference between that and
the assumed proportion in the null
hypothesis that's what this little zero
says
that this is the assumed population
proportion from the null hypothesis and
you divide that by the standard
deviation the assumed standard deviation
of the sampling distribution of the
sample proportions so that would be
our assumed population proportion times
1 minus our assumed population
proportion divided by our sample size
and in future videos we're going to go
all the way and calculate this and then
look it up in a z table and see what's
the probability of getting that extreme
or more extreme of a result and compare
it to alpha